what is up everybody so good to see you
I've almost lost my voice it's not
because I'm always screaming but we've
done so many live streams it's like
we've been gone for a while and it's
been all this pent-up energy and we're
just breaking it on you right now I'm so
thrilled happy Friday first of all happy
Friday we're back with another episode
of Louisville therapy logotherapy with
Marcus and hadeel you guys know how this
works we go over to logos from two
designers it's two by two and we're
happy this is happening today so first
up is Marcus French he's hailing from
Hamburg Germany and this is Marcus work
it's amazing
guys check out his work links in the
description below and then also we have
hadeel Syed Ahmad
she's hailing from Amman Jordan and her
work is also super amazing check out her
work okay we're gonna good job whoever
it is okay so up first up first we have
gentleman who submitted his logo to be
reviewed his name is Adam hands consoles
I think I don't know where he's from
I'm not gonna say it but this is the
logo that he sent in I'm just curious
what marks is gonna do with this so mark
is welcome back sir how are you doing
today wait your office is different
today or you did you move something
around yeah I have some minor upgrades
and you Mike
new lights Wow okay I like it okay
excellent okay so let's get into it okay
so film presentation for you before we
start I want to give you some background
information okay because the client is
called Ben Hansen and who is declined
it's a damaged furniture brand right and
you can see here share something to
craft okay some backward information
about the company itself and founded in
1948 and they craft a solid
furniture with high quality materials in
a timeless design and they are very
famous for their professor the
preeminent chair mm-hmm
no I want to bear in mind it's the chair
Fremont chair okay so those two pictures
actually of the diesel and furniture
they sell and you can include see they
are from Denmark so it felts in the
category the Scandinavian interior
design right slice can have a lot of
wood lines and I just wanna very quick
write down what are the main aspects of
the Scandinavian interior design so we
can understand why I have things later
in that process so a the AMA C entire
interior is painted white because to
keep the space right right the M there
are very long winters in Denmark and
Scandinavia so they try to brighten
everything up and when I use colors
they're always the soft and understated
use okay I said before a lot of wood
like woods like pine ash Beach to keep
to keep it bright and he used on the
floor on the walls and of course on the
furniture itself and of course they have
always alliances it is modern functional
and we see no excessive detailing and
the last is reduction and this means to
keep his face free of clutter and
unnecessary junk
oh sorry four main aspects I wanted to
show you and that leads us to the second
question does the logo 50 brand and
these are some core values i extracted
extracted form from the things we
cast a shell q so the the brand is wants
to be clean
premium a high classic feel old timeless
modern humor trick and simple you know
when we have a look this is their
current logo and then Hansel did a
exploration and yeah like we seen before
in this screenshot right and just want
to correct breaking down what we see
here first of all the typography they
use the serif font called great bold and
of course it has a very classy and
timeless look to it but also it's not
very geometric or modern
so the mark itself there's a circle with
the initials Elsa negative space inside
and it's some sort of handwritten style
it's merged together and it's they're
three bold I like that but it's also
fluffy like when you look around here
the corners and everything looks a bit I
don't know it's just sooo not precise so
I think we can improve that this is like
I said the current logo and tasty
explorations for Lebanon Hansel on phone
he didn't respond to my requests and so
I had to take the screenshot right right
his post I'm actually logo is black
background itself so this time I want to
show you my process but like I filmed
myself
sketching because I don't feel so very
confident and sketching in Photoshop and
oh you've been breaking out the compass
here which to you old school I like it
yeah I forgot yeah thanks I forgot to
switch the autofocus off so
you will see a lot of my hands all the
time
sharp it's okay we can yeah yeah yeah so
what I was trying is to use the B as the
main shape and place the letter H inside
so we can keep the current logo
something the aspect of the circle with
the negative space inside so we can keep
that and also fuse that with the
expiration Adam did and trying here do
different things and I had the idea to
place the H inside and to look at like a
chair so we can clearly see what the
company does just by looking at the logo
because there's a famous for their
chairs the premium chair and I wanted to
focus on that so it when you when you
see a look at the logo you instantly
else okay they do something with
furniture or share something like that
mm-hmm
do you often use a compass while
sketching or do you freehand it sorry
when you're sketching like this in a
notebook do you often use a compass or
do you freehand it I use it use a
compass okay not very good in drawings
so what comes with my hands like yeah
not be precise so I use a confidence I
say okay Jonah did his voice Skype out
or is it yeah yeah I did okay hopefully
our Internet's gonna hold up here yeah
I'm gonna ask Rick yeah I think it's on
his end right it could be uh I think it
was on ours it is yeah I'm
and straight into Ethernet okay great
okay so you're trying to incorporate the
H as the negative or counter inside the
B you're also trying to think about how
you can give a nod to the the iconic
chairs that they design right that's
right okay cool yes so I did try to make
it within an Oakland negative space and
try different things different
proportions and yeah yeah can we have a
hundred eleven people watching live
right now it's grown steadily over the
few minutes that we've been live welcome
everybody wherever you're from just say
hello to us I see somebody saying hi
from Egypt welcome to the future we're
in case you're just tuning in right at
this minute in a second you don't have
to rewind you can say live with us
what we're doing today is logotherapy we
have two amazing logo designers and you
guys have submitted your logos to the
facebook site or the Facebook page and
Marcus has picked this logo to take on
now both he and hadeel have picked
something that I thought was really
difficult I usually like to start off
with really ugly marks mark said I'd
like this anything I do just if I
typeset this and Helvetica is gonna
improve but these are no ordinary people
these are not no ordinary logo designers
so they pick for some really hard ones
to tackle because people are saying in
the comments the first one was pretty
good first one's pretty good so now it's
like the pressure is on to improve upon
that yeah it is I felt that something is
missing
I had clearly this picture in my mind to
implement a chair inside a level but I
mean come on it's like super obvious so
I think
I can do that now when you're when
you're scrolling through the feed and
looking for a logo to redesign what's
your thought process like how are you
deciding to pick one logo versus another
actually it's kind of the opposite by me
and when I see a very ugly logo and I
have very have absolutely no connection
to it oh that's interesting
no oh did we lose Marcus he's still okay
hang tight Marco there yeah let's see
yeah okay okay this is the final sketch
I did yeah to have a better look I've
white space before Hansel yeah yeah okay
we get it you're gonna fill it in so
that was my sketching process right
after that we go in we jump right into
illustrator and
I want to say hello to people tuning in
from Morocco I'm sorry go ahead
yeah we're right in the illustrator and
I'm setting my basic grip up it's a very
simple construction this time so it's
takes no time
[Music]
you have snap two grids on right every
time look like a true German it's like I
don't freehand I only use compass
beautiful beautiful okay okay I'm gonna
take this moment to say hello from
people that are tuning in from all over
the world we have people from Algeria
Morocco from far and distant places like
West Michigan from Montreal hopefully I
said that right we have people from
Temecula Syria hello South Africa
Germany Serbia Pakistan New Jersey's in
the house
Macedonia Wow Macedonia hello Istanbul
Finland okay let's get back into it so
your drawing this thing basically you're
kind of reconstructing in Illustrator
what you were penciling out before right
yeah yeah so you're drawing a really
thick and chunky B that's filling most
of the square and we'll get we'll get
into this a little bit whoa it's
happening pretty quick now yes I'm
getting I'm getting yes you are
interesting now why don't why did you
decide to cut back the corners like that
and I think it's something called like
bleeding edges I think and I had to feel
that it gifts boost to a chair itself so
you can recognize it better that the
object so that you know it is a chair
when you look at it yeah and also it
looks cry nice and some spice it creates
a a little bit of a three-dimensional
quality yeah like it throws a little
drop shadow or cast shadow or I should
say not drop shadow onto itself yeah
mm-hmm and that's my basic grid and the
construction itself no I'm trying to add
some type
very quick Zhi Zhu Zhi Zhu is saying I
can't wait to see the final result
me neither well okay
Marcus I want to ask you a question yeah
I noticed that when you were hitting the
keyboard you hit it with like a certain
kind of like authority like boom boom
cuz I can hear you hittin the keys I I
used my keyboard like that to my wife
saw that can you just be a little bit
more gentle like why does it have to be
so violent what's your explanation I
need to use your explanation yeah good
question
sometimes my my mouse pad or my keyboard
don't recognize my my click so I have to
[Laughter]
the view you do as I say keyboard okay
that's right do keyboards have feelings
I guess not stolen
now whatever dude whatever yeah you just
ignore me fine whatever a little hurt
but that's totally cool okay what type
face are using here um it's called I
know you owned a lot but hear me out
before you just because and because they
already used this font on their website
okay so what make sense make sense which
you said and it's also it's very clean
and it's not too constructed or
geometric it has still some character
yeah a little humanistic here and there
yeah yeah I think that is something we
need to convey in the logo okay now I'm
just cleaning up the client alignment
there
yeah the alignment right I'm setting up
the clear space
and after that it's dumb what's the unit
measure for that box that you drew like
why choose that size why not something
smaller or bigger how did you determine
that size I didn't know I tried
different different proportions mm-hmm
and actually 1/2 of an exploration file
in Illustrator with tons of vectorized
sketches and different proportions at
any end I came up with this and it
filled it felt good it felt balanced and
so I was like okay I'm gonna go take
this and yeah finalize it so I think we
had till the end so there so there's a
question here because PU she's asking
why did you move from serif to
sans-serif you mentioned this already
but case you're tuning in late why did
you do that why'd you move from San
serif to serif to San serif like I said
before I think do the serif font has
still classy and much more traditional
feeling traditional feeling yeah so I
wanted to keep it some modern and modern
look a timeless feel and I think that is
just not possible with serif font okay
so know I've done with just sketching
and the vectorizing this is the file I'm
just wanted to explain what I was
thinking when I'm constructing too so
obviously it's the letter B
and inside you let it age and also it is
a chair and when you look down on the
chair it feels like it looks like a
screw or stool something like that in
the negative space underneath the H
space here open counter so it's clearly
obvious that this company does something
with crafting or constructing and this
is the feel I want to convey in the logo
itself see that
any word it yeah mm-hmm
I think it is working but it's still not
as good as some simple black on white
and now we can compare to two logos the
current logo with my exploration on the
right mm-hmm on the right and the
original on the left that's right yes
and I also show you the comparison with
the exploration Adam did just like
mm-hmm
and oh a vacations okay I had some a few
mock-ups and I tried to build a little
landing page where you can actually shop
their furniture because know I'm in at
their website you can't shop online
they're the products so I thought it
would be cool if we can make actually an
online shop
and yeah some stationery here
business card and maybe some leather
stamping on their cousins would be nice
as a little branding and yeah I like
that so the kind of a stamped leather
feel to that d-box yeah mm-hmm and we're
done beautiful job okay let's take a
look at the progression from the
original to yours and also Adams versus
yours so that we can take a look at that
oh yeah here we go okay so on the left
everybody that's tuning in is the
original mark this is a real company
bent Hanson and they're Scandinavian
furniture company and they're famous for
their their chair right yeah yes and
they use a serif typeface with a
circular mark on icon on the right that
is using some kind of brush and hand
lettered BH icon there are some issues
to be resolved it has a certain
signature feel to it but in Marcus's
estimation it felt incongruent with
Scandinavian modern furniture but that's
just his point of view and that's okay
all right so he designed a mark that has
multiple meanings if you look deep
deeper into it this B and then embed it
inside the B is the H and the H has been
designed in such a way that there's two
hidden images in there a chair or
reference to a chair like thing and then
perhaps the negative space underneath
that like that little screw he was
talking about
so talking about craft for construction
assemblage something like that he paired
it up with one of his favorite typefaces
monserrate which is one of those free
typefaces that everybody loves no need
to defend it at all if you like and you
like it and he liked it because it was
clean and it has some humanistic quality
to it so didn't feel too cold okay so
now let's compare that to Adams logo so
Adam has done some kind of
interpretation himself so on the left is
Adam's logo so he's also done some kind
of really nice H and B B and H together
so one of my initial problems with it is
I read the H before I read the B and so
I think where as Marcus exploration has
a B its strong its bold and then the H
is secondary which I think aids in the
memory of this but I thought the
original not original the the redesign
from Adams Adam was was really nice it
kind of has also that monogram kind of
vibe to it it has some character let us
know in the comments below did you
prefer the original original which is
the serif typeface with the circular
logo and the brush script drawing do you
prefer Adams logo we'll call that number
2 or do you prefer the more modern and
clean and simple version that marks it
we'll call that number 3 so go ahead and
type in the comments below 1 for the
original 2 for Adams version or 3 the
one that you just saw Marcus demonstrate
that's number 3 go and let it is know
what you prefer
beautiful job round of applause for
Marcus please everybody okay thank you
very much so stop your share so that
yeah we can then talk about who's up
next
good job who's up next is Phillipe see
pose and here's his mark and I'm a
little nervous for her deal but I
shouldn't because I know she's a rock
star she's a rock star so this is a
company called origami and I don't know
anything else about it but I just want
to say this is beautiful if I were your
logo design instructor I'd give you an
aid Philippe so beautiful job
now now ideal is gonna do something
any minute now a deal we'll do something
because you know I do mod not I'm not
mad
hi hello so good to hear your voice
again now I can hear you but I can't see
you yet that's okay we'll just talk for
a little bit maybe Jonah can cut to my
face yeah we'll talk okay a deal there's
a little story we need to update our
audience so you guys know this or maybe
you don't know this that people do reach
out to me actually more frequently now
and asked me do you do creative service
we'd like to hire you and to which I say
thank you and no I do not but I know
many people that can help you and if you
let me know what your budget is and what
you need I can recommend somebody
so such was the case with ideal and
we'll talk about that on a different
episode but I was able to help connect
to people who I like this client and her
deal together and you just work together
and that client is thrilled is thrilled
he wants to come on the show and talk
about how wonderful the process is and
maybe we'll do that how was your
experience like with this client we did
a little bit design called got her a
stick
cutter stick mmm yeah I was super
excited to work with him he's a perfect
cut clients Wow perfect client I
absolutely loved working with him
especially with working with the
startups and people starting from their
own homes
you can feel the passion so yeah so I
want to say this I want to say this
before we get in I'm sorry to cut you
off I want to say this if you're
watching this and you own a company if
you're looking to rebrand and you have
at minimum $5,000 for a logo just $5,000
for a low got minimum we prefer
somewhere north like twenty thirty
thousand dollars if you have that in you
need help and you want me to connect you
to some of the amazing people that are
on our show or people are in our network
just reach out to me let me know that's
it okay a deal we're ready to go the
people are waiting okay hi everyone I'm
a little nervous today I understand I
understand I'm nervous - I'm nervous for
you I'm nervous myself
okay
ok let's go for it yes so this is a
local by Philip Cephas he's uh he's a
designer from the Czech Republic he
actually started as a chef there and
then he moved to Portland Oregon and
established a design agency origami
origami stood here we had a Skype
conversation that's what very
interesting to know how he came to a
career shift which I did so that was
very interesting
originally he submitted the logo only
with the with a side face he didn't add
an icon and that was a long time ago I
see and then when I reach out to him he
added the icon he wanted something for
the triangle with soft colors the colors
he used or the coral reef the fountain
the fountain coral reef if you remember
yes color of the year kind of thing yeah
he's on he's on trend yeah yeah yeah so
this is the color palette
he used so let's go for it
so he's the project over a year overview
we just mentioned everything it's a
design studio let me mention that
designing for other designers is very
hard yes it is
yes yeah because it's I hope Philippe
likes the the rebranding and I said to
him that if he does I'm gonna offer him
all of the files and he can use
everything Wow yeah I hope he does like
it ok so study origami provides a
strategy based design they design
develop brand identities websites and
products missus demographics and the
most important thing that I asked him
was what are the the your design
implementation is gonna be where your
logo is going to live because this
episode we are talking about mock-ups so
I wanted to know which mode and this is
what I do actually in all of my projects
I need to set the design implementation
and decide on the motifs before I start
yeah so I can visualize and I open all
of the mocks before I start designing so
I can visualize how the design and the
identity going to be placed everywhere
sometimes yeah it may be you can change
your your decisions based on the
mock-ups you're getting use so basically
he's gonna use them on a stationary
website you I post on posters and
invitations and greeting cards okay and
of course before I do my my design I do
my research so I went to the origin I
looked the meaning of origami of course
I know what is origami everyone knows
what it what it is but when you research
you find golden nuggets you know origami
it's from or a meaning folding and
County meaning paper it's the art of
paper folding where the goal is to
transform a flat square sheet of paper
into a finished sculpture through
folding and sculpting techniques so we
start with a square to get to the final
sculpture I feel nugget coming I would
not lead I would not jump to conclusions
but I I see what you're doing here so
here's the brand attributes he wanted it
to be memorable modern simple and he
focused on simple and minimal and
elegant the his tagline is all or
nothing which I love because mine is do
it with passion or not at all
and here's the thing that I like to do
this is the decision roadmap and the
last project he named it decision
science and this is what I do for every
project sometimes I show it to the
client some shots sometimes I don't
mm-hmm this is what I take from the all
of my research and the meeting with the
client and based on it I come and come
back to it every time to when every time
I need to make a decision at the design
process so starting with origami is the
art of trance
a flat square sheet of paper so this is
very important you can't start with a
rectangle or any other shape you have to
have a flat square sheet of paper and
then you can turn it into a sculpture
using folding techniques and on lines
these lines to get the final yes product
the most common angle used in origami is
a 45-degree angle of course other
degrees are used but this is the most
common one and Phillipe told me that he
he does with the brand strategy for his
clients and he focuses on that so so how
do I convey that into the the local
design the local type should be placed
before the logo icon symbolizing the
implementation of brand strategy before
the design process and the local design
should be minimal modern so it can be
engraved on embossed logo needs to be
flat with a solid color execution can't
be in 3d secures the local design should
not be a direct usage of an overly used
origami shape so doing get the research
and immediately when you think of
origami almost every design has an
animal especially this bird so this is
the cliche the overly used shapes we
need to avoid that so I was looking into
when I did my research and I was looking
into shapes that I want to copy now in
this project
I didn't sketch I didn't have to go into
too many local explorations because I
did it backwards I wanted to find a
shape that I liked and I think that
works good with the for my client and
the project and then just draw it and
Victor eyes it and use it mm-hmm
so the mood board has the square sheets
I liked some some shapes here and the
triangles and of course the original
logo had a triangle which really wanted
to keep so I like this pattern which you
can make into a wall art and I actually
did build one and you can use it in many
different ways and then I built this one
and based on it
this is actually the the origami that I
did for the local I had to do with on
paper multiple times to learn how to do
it rise it this is financial I'm going
to use I love how thorough you are in
your process and people are saying that
as well and showing your thinking
because a lot of times you will see the
final mark and they're like yeah why is
that special why did we get here and
you're doing something that Paul ran is
famous for doing when he goes and
presents a logo to a giant corporation
he actually prints out a beautiful book
and it takes him through the thinking
process so by the time you get to n logo
there's really nothing else to ask
there's no revisions anything you paid
for the logo this is a logo you get you
get no revisions that's it use it or
don't it's up to you yeah it's very
convincing I see that for the clients
yeah mm-hmm so this is the
transformation from the flat square
sheet of paper into the icon mm-hmm of
course this is an abstract version of
the paper one yes and I also have to use
a square inside so I change the two
triangles inside into a square mm-hmm
and here's the local icon this is what
I'm gonna use I'm gonna show you a quick
video or half-hour but it was really
fast process okay great and just let you
know Philippe is tuned in live right now
he is watching a little bit but don't
worry he's excited I was debating
whether I should tell you that or not
but I wanted to get a genuine reaction
my designers good job started with an
empty artboard of course and then III
add a grid even if I don't actually use
the idea oh we're not seeing the video
something happen you have to stop that
chair yet should they stop and then yes
yes stop to share and then we share yeah
I'll pick the application
okay yes okay just a second take your
time I'm wondering why you're doing that
and you know have you given a lecture
have you spoken about you this exact
process before I do speak at events
workshops and actually we do have one at
the end of this month but what I'm doing
is I'm writing a book Wow yeah it's
called how to design a logo I like that
title yeah okay so I'm gonna put in
every single detail of how I design a
logo every little secret I have and
especially this process because the most
difficult thing for designers is how to
think how to come up with ideas how to
come up with solid ideas that your
client can say no to so this is what I'm
doing I'm hoping I will relaunching and
publishing next year because I have too
many projects to stop and focus on it
but I think it's gonna be very helpful
for designers okay well if you need help
promoting that book or if you're doing a
Kickstarter just let me know and I'll do
what I can on my end I'm actually
counting on you I'm pretty committed to
this idea got it of course so can you
see the video yes we're ready you see so
started with the grid even if I don't
actually use the the number of the small
grids inside but it feels just to make
everything visually balanced so I
started with a hexagon this is the
fastest way to start with the to build
the the basic shape of their logo icon
mm-hmm just align the align it to the
grid okay it's applicated it so now and
the intersection I have the basic shape
I'm using using geometrical shapes in
your process
makes the the the local variables yeah
it's better than just using a pen tool
and just starting doing your tangles the
way you want yes mm-hmm irritation
45-degree angle remember everything and
the decision science it's at 45-degree
angle
aligned it with the basic shape and
started adding lines those of the fold
lines yeah family the square and the two
lines I grouped them and then I'm gonna
color the the basic shape at the back
and then I'm gonna add a stroke to the
folding lines just to where I think it's
good enough and I like how it comes out
from the shape here and I'm adding this
star it's a four point star and to make
sure that it looks good and legible I
align it with the square and then
enlarge it to half of that square and
just put it in the middle expand the
strokes and then just delete them from
the shape behind mm-hmm using minus
front
yeah yep and here's the look like wow so
simple yeah beautiful let's talk a
little bit about why why use geometric
shapes when drawing the logo I have my
theory I want to hear a little bit more
about why you think so important why do
you think it adds balance to the mark
itself because the geometric shapes are
already balanced so when you use them
the anyone's eye is not very accurate
you can't draw a perfect circle and when
I want it let's say I want to throw this
shape with my pen to it I'm gonna put a
point here maybe a point there maybe
another point here which is not aligned
together yes using the hexagon the
intersection is just perfect I don't
have to
keep on editing and underlining
everything yeah it works every time
but sometimes if we have a very organic
shape you have to draw it with pen tool
in that case I start with a sketch
because I can control my pen and then
scan and Victory's yeah watching you go
through your process of how you arrived
at this and it warms my heart it really
does because when I was in the trenches
designing myself either as a student or
a person who's working I did crazy
things like if you're gonna do an
origami project it's time to learn about
origami it's time to go get a piece of
paper and fold and you learn things and
I'm probably not gonna get this quote
exactly right but Michael Beirut says
there's actually very little creativity
and logo design and it's one of those
comments like what like what would you
say that there's very little creativity
and I think what is meant by that is
that when you understand the problem so
well that it seems to dictate what you
have to do like as a result of logical
decisions and 'muslim of Vignelli's says
something very similar and it's no
surprise because he was Michael Beirut's
mentor so when you go through this
process you start with your paper and
you look at it as you're folding it you
know what other shape could it be it has
to be this shape so you're not trying to
force your own idea for something that
you wanted to recycle from something
else
you just look at the problem and it
appears and if you watch Michael Beirut
talk about his process for some really
big big brand big-name companies he
sometimes he messes up he was like I
tried this and I don't know what I was
thinking but then eventually I saw this
and this is how we determined everything
else using these circle was I'm black
yes and as I said in the decision slide
oh did we just lose the live stream yeah
what happened oh we're back yeah we're
back we're back okay okay sorry how do
you buy yeah okay so again this is
Gotham black and I say as I mentioned it
the decision slides I added five face
first and then the icon the logo I can I
just did some little too
on the the the typeface I had a cut on
the M over here and then made a looks
looked like the logo I can just to have
consistency between the type and the
logo - mm-hmm and this is the local
construction and clear space the 100% is
actually a square the height of the
typeface here format and it's duplicated
at the the the ends and the logo icon is
a 200% also calculating the spaces
between the logo I can and the other is
realistic mark and I can hey mm-hmm and
here's a responsive logo a responsive
local is a variation of the same logo
that they that have smaller versions so
you can use them in smaller areas so
here's the full logo with the tagline is
the the the logo hit that he's gonna use
the most and he's the smaller one I just
took the star from the other guy can add
it in there oh and we're gonna use this
just in just a bit and this is the
favicon so he can use this and it's it's
little bit yeah so taking this we're
going into ports I can't do just know I
know I know I would expect nothing less
from you thank you
so taking this this local I just did
this is not the main the main pattern
it's just a pattern from the identity
it's used as duct tape or as stickers
yep package packing tape something like
that yeah exactly so here's the colors
I'm gonna use I switched from the
original color he was using because I
thought but but also stayed a little bit
near them so I took a coral reef and I
made it a bit of a red color the black
is a navy color now and I added the blue
and I want to mention something here so
this is the original typeface but using
it on dark backgrounds this is actually
thinner the letters are thinner than
this one because of course I see yeah
for optical optical reasons yes you
choke the weight a little bit right yeah
yes okay here's the website this is
actually his website this is the one
he's using now with with the old logo
and the colors he's using so I took a
screenshot and I edited here with locals
and the identity system I'm gonna show
you now so this is the mate
oh something happened did we lose you oh
something happened something happened
okay kick you for one second we're
seeing some who's desktop is that
oh no we're having a meltdown give a
second good a second sorry you guys we
have really fast internet here but for
some reason I don't think we're
connected to that fast internet we're
back okay
sorry just rewind a little bit deal and
start that part again it's saying like
the internet it's unstable is that our
sink this is the future and we're in the
present okay and you know are you back
or do we lose you yeah yeah I can hear
you now
oh my gosh I scream yes we can it is the
main patterns yeah yes okay thank you
the main pattern this is actually a gif
if you can see you yes what I did is go
back to the decision slide again and we
have to do some magic editing to
resuscitate this one yeah guys okay I
know there 279 of you guys thank you for
your patience we're working on this as
you can see it's been a little while
since we've been broadcasting live and
we were literally just days back from
Adobe MAX the gears not even been
totally unpacked
the guy's the team have scrambled to
make this happen for us
so I apologize I am usually at this
point I would be freaking out like no no
what are you doing Ricky's fired right
but I'm not because we're all tired and
we're all just trying to make it happen
so hang in there
and while Jonah's getting everything
back on line and reconnecting all our
servers and the Internet
there were some questions about this hat
and about how I'm working with Marcus
and a deal on these live streams and
I'll tell you in a second first of all
the Hat is this abstract symbol it's
created by this designer named Raul Raul
and he's got a design company called
nothing design or nothing something
nothing it's one be 1 billion minus one
which is our mission to teach a billion
people how to make money doing what they
love without feeling gross so he did
this whole thing and there's like really
cool embroidery and I think it's on this
side yep yeah this is one billion minus
one there's some really neat details
that's got a blue rim if you can see
that it so it's on brand on brand with
the blue now to the question of how is
it I'm talking to these two designers
well here's the thing the feature is a
global community and I kind of also see
people submitting work and I think whoa
who's this a deal person she keeps doing
amazing work I'd like to see if she's
interested in becoming one of the two
hosts on the show and and I reached out
and he deal says yes and Marcus says yes
and that's how we get here so we have
actually three sets of local therapist
and we rotate between them and they just
tell me at some point because everybody
has to manage their workload and make
money and take care of the family all
that kind of stuff
everyone's all they see they shoot me a
message saying hey I'm ready to do
another session and that's how this
happens and that is the rest of the
story jonahwy back are we live okay
Ahmad says a deal really proud of you
and I think you have at least one backer
for the book somebody's like I'm ready
to buy the book pre-order right now and
now Nathan's like you want this hat
we'll let you guys know how to get this
hat we will have them for sale the ideas
as enroll is the super generous person
he said basically all profit will go to
to support a scholarship fund we haven't
worked that out yet but once he recoups
the net cost of each hat he will then
donate the rest of the money to the
Future ten to dish
that as scholarship so I want to take a
point to also welcome people who are
possibly in and I don't know markets
that are a lot tougher developing
markets like Ghana Nigeria
maybe Indonesia wherever you're at we're
working on plans on how to get our
educational content our courses to you
for a little to no money so hang in
there we got to make some money to keep
the lights on to keep these lights on
and continue to produce the show and pay
for our internet outside of that outside
of that we want to help you okay we hear
you we hear you that even in some of our
lower price classes like the typography
course that goes for $2.99
that it's it's still a lot of money and
we want to help so Raul the 1b -1 1
billion -1 project so if you guys have
been impacted by some of the content
here and it's helped you get inspiration
to find your way back to design to not
give up to negotiate to value yourself
or to communicate or learn a new skill
use that hashtag hashtag 1 be like 1
billion won be minus 1 oh and E 1 be
minus 1 use that hashtag and be counted
John are we back we're back hopefully
fingers crossed we can make this work I
I hear how do ok ideal the animated gif
can you see me I can see it yes we're
back ok so this is the main pattern yes
again we're starting from a square yes
and the final destination that we want
to gonna have is the stilted diamonds
yes from the logo so a 90-degree angle
squared is rotated 9 times there it
each time I rotated five at a five
degree angle
mm-hmm until I got the 45 degree angle
and cut the diamond and just replicate
appreciated everyone just like this way
and vertical and horizontal way and I
got this one and here is some posters so
this is the messaging that philip is
using we give it all we have one plate
at a time one project at a time
nice and this is his tagline these
graphical elements are taken from the
local as well and the local will be at
the at the base and these lines are why
I decided to use these lines they are
they are influenced from the folding
techniques and the creases every time
you want to learn how to do origami you
have you see the lines that decreases
sometimes they are intact lines
sometimes they are adopted yes this is
how what influenced the design and of
course everything is in a square so I
didn't do this
part of the poster didn't extend over
it's just a square okay and here's some
mock-up and applications some bag the
front and the back using the the pattern
so we're using it when posters I'm using
it on the bags and everything else even
the the mock-ups decisions was
influenced by the decision slide I have
the the background is also tilted at a
45 degree angle and these ones a folder
and an envelope and here's some business
cards mmm again with the lines his name
using the colors and I'm not sure if you
can see this but the local is a embossed
obvious
well I my screen is tiny but I'm sure
it's obvious can you see it Jonah you
can see it okay I don't want to lie and
say I can see it but yeah it's fine I'm
going to show you the actual Makkah
point and here are some others here's
the local stitch on a cup and I want to
talk about this just a little bit these
are actual origami sculptures that I did
and I photograph them and then cut them
and meet them into a mock-up as stand
for the business card mm-hmm you
actually made that
yeah okay yeah
if you can but cut to my camera I'm
gonna show you the actual sculptures
yeah a bit yeah well hold it up hold it
up the camera we barely saw it there we
go now we can see it oh yeah I didn't
see myself so these are the ones that I
did this is the one that I photograph
doing and this is the white one yes I
was in the mood for it I'm gonna use
this again okay so these the one
photographed and used
mm-hmm it's nice to have real ones
because of course you can't find
mock-ups with origami it's really hard
right that's one and here's the fruit of
fusing and buying actually really good
mock-ups this one it's really hard to
make by yourself so this is a really
good mock-up they purchased from mr.
mock-up mm-hmm I purchased one did the
the business card bond bundle and the
corporate stationery bundle so this is
the business card and the business card
holder and I cut the business card of
course without the star I've got the
star well in reality wouldn't it
wouldn't say there yeah but it when you
put the business card inside it will
show in here mm-hmm
and this is the cut secondary pattern I
usually create more than one pattern for
the for my brands mm-hmm nineties I'm
90% of the times and this is taken from
the other the logo itself this can be
used as well as wrapping paper and on
areas you want to to place
color but without any type yes very nice
she's greeting card because he said he
likes to make handmade greeting cards
mm-hmm I'm gonna teach Philip if he
wants to how to create this this is a
mock-up
I already made one the envelope mm-hmm
and this I did myself and this I did
myself and this is actually inspired
from I'm not sure if I'm on Farah again
cut the camera yeah please yep we see
you yeah can you see me this is the
this is that of course without the
patent and everything and this is it
from the back and this is how it opens
Wow
and he can send that and put it in a
squared envelope and it just closes this
way and it's very cool so when his
clients receive it they will be
impressed and it's linked to origami and
the most important thing it's not very
cliche origami it's just hence for for
what it does without being too overly
use us yes like those birds right yeah
of course using the color is very
minimal here is the color palette and
again really good mock-ups show in the
details and being consistent and we're
almost done here's a t-shirt a really
good one reusing the the logo the colors
and the pattern over here and this is
the final finest slide and the poster
and the pattern and these are the one
that I just told you mm-hmm I just
photographed them but them and added
them to the data model
Anthony MacNeil saying hadeel goes the
extra mile her clients are always
satisfied
Anthony checks in the mail I'm glad you
said that when we mentioned the book I
think when we mentioned the book people
are like take my money take my money
okay so let's get this book out when you
plan to have the book ready I need to
put some time into it so I think next
year maybe in the first quarter first
quarter okay all right I just need to
stop taking on projects I just took so
many projects to make a backup and now
I'm gonna take maybe two months of work
and just focus on the book okay so right
this is the original logo yes here we go
everybody pay attention this is number
one this is logo number one
but Philippe and I think Philippe may
not be here anymore maybe he got
depressed and left I don't know I'm just
kidding
Philippe this is original logo it's
beautiful logo it really is I like it
and then logo number two is one version
with an icon that strong that's built on
Jim it GRE and patterns unfolding and I
just really love this is number two guys
so go ahead let us know in the comments
below number one or number two and this
is not just to say anything disparaging
against Philippe Philippe some logos
really great and I just I'm just curious
I mean I deal and mark is there they're
like gluttons for punishment to pick a
nice logo and then try to make it even
better or to put their own spin on it
it's just so so challenging maybe one of
these days I'm gonna do a logo challenge
myself and you'll see what my logic
looks like I'm gonna pick the ugliest
most horrendous logo is set in Comic
Sans and I'm like yeah I put in
Helvetica logo done okay really good job
so one or two guys and the votes are
coming in thanks for putting in your
votes and what I deal always does I
shouldn't say always but it seems like
it's a pattern now where she'll take an
idea based on understanding and blow it
out in a thousand different ways and
every time you think she's done like
scrolling down like okay now I got one
more no I I mean I have ten more let me
show you ten more things I've done so it
really is complete and when you do this
for your clients I have to imagine a
deal your clients must be thrilled it's
like it's like their birthday or
something you say that like a stone-cold
assassin your logo assassin is coming
like gotcha I got it taken care of okay
okay we're coming to the end of the show
here I want to thank everybody for
tuning in oh you have something else you
wanna say I do yeah please really fast
oh yes I wanna see you yeah I want to
see the mock-ups yes please go ahead is
that on camera oh yes okay yes we yeah
mm-hmm okay no I don't want you to see
me I want you to see the the Photoshop
okay a Photoshop I say sure that you
have to share that I never stop sharing
this oh yes
okay hang in there there's over 300
people watching okay Philippe is still
here he's here
he says hit deals process is impeccable
late night canvasses I would like I
would die to see Chris take on a logo
well I don't wanna lose the subscriber
so I'm not going to do that so I was
thinking about launching a logo
challenge between designers on Instagram
maybe mm-hmm
maybe you can start me and you we can
take the same brief and then design the
each of us can design a logo and we can
let the people vote okay okay notice how
serious ideas be present your logo like
and this is my last light and now it's
done it's perfect and then now when it's
like Chris I challenge you now you're
laughing it's like yeah I don't wear
this gun this isn't wrapped yeah I was
actually thinking about asking other
designers yes and maybe it would be
hosted by you or I don't know I think
people see me fail so I may be up for
chance we'll talk about this afterwards
and depending on foreigners and what we
got going on yes I theoretically accept
theoretically except I will have to rely
on completely bias 100% dedicated loyal
fans to vote me up that's all I can
count on I can't win on a fair fight you
guys know this so donation if we do this
donation step up you're gonna have to
vote for me otherwise I'm not gonna do
this okay they're saying do it do it
okay fine okay show us the mock-ups so
as I said before these are from mr.
Moffat I purchase the bundle so what you
do this is the card I'm gonna eat it so
what we do in mock up will you buy them
you
load the PSD file and then just go for
the the smart object that you're gonna
change it's usually says your design
goes here or your logo goes here
whatever yes you just double-click on it
right you just add your design you know
it's a smart object
mm-hmm yeah it's a smart object do you
design it on illustrator and then you
drag and drop it in here and just click
Save mm-hmm and then you it
automatically automatically adds the the
effect the lights and everything for you
right and as for the embassy art what
makes buying mock-ups really a good
investment is that you can do an emboss
yourself but of course and there's an
option for addy boss both I did an
emboss oh there's really pre-built you
just got to turn it on yeah it's rebuilt
and it's actually really really good
this is a good night
yeah you just add your design over here
and the one hand the thing that you want
to also have it embossed and you either
or the other other side I see and very
simple but in this in this mock-up I
edited each business card and other
mock-ups you a edit the master and it
changes all over okay so this is one
it's really easy that if every time
people ask me about mock-up so they
think that it's something it's a secret
or something it's the simplest thing in
the world just don't don't be a Steve
click on the smart object add your
design save it and just it it sometimes
I let on the light so I add some depth
eye shadows whatever and again this is
one of the mock-ups I took it
added this one it's actually it's
grouped mm-hmm this is a separate
mock-up than the background
I just layered them and add the shadows
and add my logo and everything this is
your own makeup right what this is the
one that you created
yeah there's the one I created it's just
pen tool I do
shape and then the shadows I just
created it and and they duplicated this
and added in here yeah with this are you
gonna create your own mock-ups and sell
them no not interested actually okay
just asking because it takes too much
time but when if if a project needs it I
just go for it and this is the a gif one
I don't know if we have the time I just
create so it was if you remember three
I'm gonna go through this pretty fast
hoping someone with good benefits I use
gif salat and my presentations and for
my clients and on be hands so it's
really simple these are let me move this
these are three layers the ones that I
did I just go to windows timeline and
here they are I just know that when the
first one ends the second starts and I
just tell how much I want the it to stay
maybe I want to be really fast or maybe
I wanted the last longer and then you
save it as a GIF I see a deal showing us
all her tricks guys this is valuable
stuff here in case you're wondering how
to integrate gifts into your
presentations okay and this is the final
thing I'm gonna add it to my Behance
presentation I'm going to float it or
publish it now this this is will be the
intro for my behan spirit presentation
it's a video with the local all and why
we're not seeing it we're not seeing it
something I probably I think when you
switch apps or something yeah so can you
see it yes yes okay it's a video mm-hmm
with the logo overlay is this your hand
no okay I looked for a video that has
something looking like
origami or sometimes hold it yeah I'm
just I'm gonna add it to my behance
presentation when we were done with the
episode to upload it for everyone to see
beautiful that's it
and and that ladies and gentlemen is how
you do a case study logo design behance
projects so that you can get work at the
level which both our participants today
both logo therapists have produced work
my imagination is they're gonna do quite
well on search and and hopefully use
these things as lead generation tools so
if you're watching this episode and you
want to reach out further we're gonna
include links down below to both so
there are behance pages and so if you
like to work hire them pay them lots of
money and treat them well and they will
take good care of you okay a couple
things I want to say before we wrap up
the show today the first thing I want to
say is this first thank you to both of
you I miss you I miss you and and maybe
in between writing the book and
everything else that you're doing we can
get you to come back on the show more
regularly and I think that would be
awesome if we can do that okay so thank
you both you bottom my heart I'm a
little rusty
what's that Jonah no I can't - early no
that's okay don't worry no we're not
doing this yet don't know go to this
it's fine just stay on me I'm still
talking Thank You Jonah and enough right
bullet yeah I'm back okay so guys hire
them pay the lots of money and again if
you are a company and you're looking to
improve your visual identity and you'd
like to hire somebody from our broad
community just reach out to me let me
know at the minimum it has to be $5,000
I cannot consider anything less than
that we gotta raise the stakes here and
I know a lot of designers we're gonna
work really hard to help you do a great
job they're gonna just do an amazing job
okay to the point of the logo design
challenge I have to ask you a couple of
questions ideal if I agree to this do I
have to design it myself or can I use my
entire team to use to do the logo for me
okay she's that company guys this is
Wonder Woman here she's I use whoever
you have all she's like leonidas in 300
just like bring them on
slaughter every single person right now
okay both it's funny that you mentioned
the Wonder Woman that's all that no I
I see everything you see I just don't
miss anything okay
so she's like Santa and all you Legion
send in the Untouchables The Immortals
I'll take over all I'll take care of all
your wife okay you know yeah people are
saying I can buy their vote so everybody
that votes for me I'm gonna send your
free course now I'm just kidding okay
that's it guys we gotta get out of here
it's we're way over time thank you both
so much and thank you all 300 plus
people who stayed in we're going to be
producing a lot more content so don't
sleep on us the one B minus one project
I put the I put the link in the comments
and so hopefully general and script out
later okay let's get out of here guys
don't forget to Like comment and
subscribe and hit the bell at
notifications we love you we appreciate
you being here and especially to our
sustaining members you know who you are
you part of the fan you you're part of
the deal